goitre pardon goitre goa autres eh bien
quoi gaulle être pourrais tu me dis
goitre bas c'est joli comme mon nom
qu'on jamais ça c'est quand tu as un
problème à la thyroïde et du coup tu as
une espèce de protubérances dans le coup
pourquoi tu me dis ça à moi parce que je
viens d'apprendre que c'était bien ce
que ma grand mère appelait les crétins
des as ce qu'ils mangent trop de
raclette
non ça c'est les savoyards en fait on ne
sait pas assez mais crétinisme c'est une
maladie c'est une perte partielle ou
totale des facultés intellectuelles avec
de temps en temps une dégénérescence
physique et paf
un goitre donc crétins c'est pas une
insulte c'est maladie oui tout à fait
c'est un vrai truc les regarde
au cours du 19ème siècle on remarque pas
très très gentiment que certaines
régions du monde sont peuplées de
chrétiens alors que d'autres non mais
pourquoi les alpes et pas les pyrénées
par exemple on avait aussi dans les
pyrénées mais bon c'était surtout dans
les alpes et au lieu d'essayer de
comprendre pourquoi certains ont
pratiquement fait une attraction
touristique
la population du mont blanc est entachée
sur divers points de goitre et même
quelquefois de crétinisme les nombreuses
familles atteintes de ces maladies
languissent dans la misère quand
théophile gautier descendre la suisse à
l'italie va il adore le paysage mais il
a un peu chagriné par souvent il est
fâcheux que ce charmant paysages sont
peuplées de chrétiens et de goitreux on
rencontre à chaque pas des femmes
quelquefois joly qui sont affligés de
cette infirmité dégoûtante les bains
quel charmant monsieur ce théophile
l'empathie incarner mois mais ya
largement pire brouillonne les crétins
format cinq catégories deux catégories
de plus qu'on en compte dans la viande
de boucher c'est marrant ça ressemble
des tweets
tout à fait puis on trouve en 1886 un
recensement de la population affirme il
y aurait actuellement en france
68500 idiot crétins et goitreux
comprenant entre autres 32 1750 idiot et
crétin non goitreux 30 1254 non crétins
et 5500 goitre crétins goitre j'aime
toujours autant son mais la maladie elle
vient d'où alors alors des médecins
tentent de comprendre à quoi sont dues
cette infirmité il élabore des théories
le manque d'oxygène
la viande de deuil le gouvernement
américain les illumine est le parrain la
petite vingt mille lieues sous les mers
compte donc on parlait je suis pas assis
de l'origine du crétinisme
oui voilà alors on a longtemps cru que
ça venait de la neige fondue qui était
vu par les habitants mais en fait il a
fallu chercher plus loin en suisse
sai on est un village du valais où l'on
ne voyait depuis très longtemps que très
peu de bois traité de crétin tandis
qu'ils étaient en grand nombre dans des
villages voisins à faire par exemple il
ya quelques années un changement ayant
été apporté à l'aménagement des eaux de
la première localité les goitres s'y
sont multipliés mais c'était pas l'eau
après de nombreuses analyses ce docteur
grand cru pouvoir attribuer à la
magnésie la cause de ces engorgements
monstrueux de ces développements parfois
kystique du corps thyroïde alors c'est
le magnésium qui responsable non pas du
tout en fait il fallait plutôt trouver
ce qui manquait et ça on l'a découvert
en 1923
llyod l'agent le plus efficace à
employer contre l'endémie thyroïdiennes
c'était donc un problème de thyroïde
d'où le goitre est en fait balliol
suffit à soigner ce mal des montagnes
hockey et pierrot tu me remettra un
godet diodes s'te plaît non t'inquiète
ciboure et puissant que ça regarde on a
imaginé d'atteindre la totalité de la
population par un procédé ingénieux
consistant à mettre à la disposition de
tous un sel de cuisine
additionnée d'un peu dieu dur de
potassium l'adossé tels que la quantité
de sel est communément consommer
contient une proportion diodes
suffisante et aujourd'hui batoul et sel
de cuisine contiennent de l'yonne mais
reste quand même des crétins dans les
actes un décret tente en a partout mais
a priori baas pas à cause du mondial
dans le book
[Musique]